♪ [music] ♪
So now, that we've talked about not just
the mechanics of valuation but
how to convert a story into valuation,
let's build on that by talking
about the value of control.
What is the value of control
in the company and how do you come up
with that number? To answer that question,
I'm going to go back to a page that
you saw at the very start of this class.
I talked about how corporate finance's
built on three principles, right?
The investment principle,
the financing principle,
and the dividend principle.
Every principle in corporate finance is
embedded somewhere in your valuation
and here's how. The investment principle
drives your return on capital
and your reinvestment rate
and through your return on capital
and your reinvestment rate,
it drives your growth rate.
The financing principle
determines a financing mix you use and
the type of debt you have, and through
those numbers, it drives your cost of
capital, the discount rate you use and the
discounted cash valuation. The dividend
principle shows up in your reinvestment
rate because the more cash you choose
to return to your stockholders,
the less you reinvest.
You could actually argue that everything
in corporate finance is part of valuation
and that's effectively what I've tried to
do here. I've taken the investment
decisions that Disney has made,
translated those investment decisions
into the current operating income,
the return capital they generate and
their expected growth rate.
I've taken the financing decision,
the choice they made of 11.5% debt and
88.5% equity to come up with a cost
of capital of 7.81% that drives my
discounted cash valuation.
And the dividend decision
effects the reinvestment rate and
through the reinvestment rate drives the
growth rate and drives the value
of the company. You're saying, "Why are
we doing this?" The value that I got for
Disney as a company reflects the choices
that Disney has made on the investment,
the dividend, and the financing
principles. Could you have made different
decisions? Through this class,
we've talked about what Disney does well
and what Disney does badly, what we might
change at Disney if we ran the company
and what we would leave alone. Now,
here's your chance to bring those numbers
into play. So, here's what I did,
I decided to look at how I might be able
to change the value at Disney.
And let me step back and look at the four
parameters in my valuation that I could
potentially change by changing the way the
company is run. By changing the
way my existing assets are run,
I change my base here, cashflow. So maybe,
maybe if I'm running my existing
investments inefficiently,
by running them more efficiently I could
generate a higher operating margin
and a higher operating income.
I could try to increase the value of a
business by changing the value of growth.
The drivers of my value for growth are
my reinvestment rate and my return
on capital. If I'm earning more than
my cost of capital, if I could
reinvest more, I could increase my value
as a company because I'm increasing
the value of growth.
If I'm earning less than the cost
of capital, I could increase my value by
reducing my reinvestment rate but I could
look for ways in which I can
increase value from growth.
Perhaps, I can lower my cost of capital
by doing what? By either altering the mix
of debt and equity in my company or
changing the type of debt that I use
as a company. Remember we talked
about matching debt to assets?
So, if I have mismatched debt,
maybe by matching up my debt,
I can lower my cost of debt
and cost of capital.
And finally, perhaps I can
put off the day I become a
mature company. Remember I said that the
key variable determining when I will
become a mature company
is what kind of competitive advantages
I have. If I can build up new competitive
advantages, keep the competition at bay,
maybe I can put off the day I become a
mature company. So in summary,
I can try to increase my cash flows
and existing assets by running them
more efficiently, I can try to increase
the value of growth by changing
my reinvestment rate or altering my return
on capital, I can lower my cost of capital
by changing my mix of debt and equity and
changing the type of debt I have and push
off the day that I become a mature company
by pushing up my competitive advantages.
Everything we talk about in the context of
restructuring is somewhere in this page.
So, let's have I made you see of Disney
in November of 2013. Let's think about
some of the changes you might be able to
make. Here's the first change I tried to
make. I said, "Perhaps, Disney could fin
a different mix of reinvestment and return
on capital." That gives them only a
slightly higher growth rate but a much
higher value, and here's why.
The return on capital I assume for Disney
in November of 2013 with the status quo
was 12.61%, the reinvestment rate was 54%.
Perhaps, by reinvesting a little less,
they might be able to earn a return
on capital of 14%. That's not
an unreachable number.
In fact, prior to the capital
of Disney's ABC acquisition,
Disney's return on capital is close
to 16%. So, if I can push up my return on
capital and push down my reinvestment rate
a little bit, I'm not growing much faster
but I'm creating more value from growth.
The second change I tried to institute
was I looked at the debt ratio.
Remember when we looked at the
optimal debt ratio for Disney,
we said that the optimal mix of debt and
equity was 40% debt, 60% equity.
Let's say they could go to that mix right
away, that reduces the cost of capital
to the optimal cost of capital of 7.16%.
Those were the only two changes I made.
A slightly higher growth rate with a
higher a return on capital accompanying it
and a lower cost of capital changing
my mix of debt and equity.
With those changes put in,
the value that I get for Disney as a
company is $74.91. Remember that
my status quo value was $62.56?
With the changes I put into the company,
the value that I get is $74.91.
I've increased the value of the
company by $12.35, why?
Because I think I can run the company
better than the existing management can.
That might be the ego trip but
to the extent that I believe it,
the value of control at Disney is
$12.35. Stepping back,
here's a more general proposition.
The value of control in any company is the
difference between two values,
the status quo value and the
optimal value. To the extent that a
company's already perfectly managed and
perfectly ran, the value of control could
be zero. If it's badly managed and badly
ran, the value of control can be immense.
You're saying, "Where is the market price
fall in of all these?" The market does not
reflect either the status quo value or the
optimal value, it's an expected value.
Expected value in what sense?
If I'm investing in Disney,
I have to factor what the status quo
value is, I have to look at the optimal
value, and then I have to ask a
final question. What is the chance that
management in Disney would change?
And if the answer to that question is
greater than zero, then I have to reflect
an expected value. But that's going to
happen only if I believe that I could
change the management of a company.
So, let me connect this back
the topic we started off with
in corporate finance. We talked
about corporate governance.
We talked about corporate governance
has the capacity to change the management
of a company if we don't like the way
it's run. If you have strong corporate
governance, your market price will reflect
closer to the optimal value than
it will to the status quo value.
If you have weak corporate governance,
you're going to end up with a market price
that's close to the status quo value.
If you have no corporate governance,
no power without change, your market
prices might just reflect the status quo
value. I'm going to assume at this stage,
you have a value for your company.
I'm going to assume that that value
reflects the status quo, the existing
management of the company,
because you've done the realistic thing.
As an investor, you've said,
"This is not my company.
I'm going to value the company given
its existing practices." Now, put on,
you'll see you had. Revalue your company
with the changes you would make
and don't be surprised if you come up
with a value very different from the
status quo value, especially, if you're
looking at a company you think
is badly managed and badly run.
You've unlock the key to understanding
the value of control.
♪ [music] ♪